Hey everyone, today we've got a super exciting
video for you in which I will be taking you
through the RPG game from Freako camp that teaches
you how to code we have Mir is the game creator,
Lin. So without further ado, Lin, is there
anything you want to say before starting?
Sure, I'm Billy. I'm a recent graduate from
the University of Chicago, from my CS degree,
and now Software Engineering here at Salesforce in
San Francisco. And in my free time, as you might
see on the screen, the thing I do the most is game
development. Alright, let me tell us something
about the game. The idea first started in April,
when Quincy had this idea brewing his mind,
he reached out to me by late July, when I was
planning my move here to San Francisco. And
I jumped on this opportunity, I started my four
month long development. The process took I think,
for most times four weeks for most, times 10 plus
our promo. And that should take us to 160 hours
plots. And that's excluding the gret graphics.
Because the graphics, the graphics were done
by an artist we found, and Quincy himself
that the music. So the coding, the writing,
took me 160 hours plus, that's incredible. I mean,
I can't wait to start playing this game. That is
a lot of time and education. I know that Quincy
spent over 25 hours on the music. So everyone
watching, if you want to check that out, please
do pay attention to the music throughout this
game. If you want to make the music louder,
by the way, you can adjust the volume here.
So this is the music volume, which is actually
different to the sound volume of the game itself.
So as you can see here, we are just
changing the sound volume, which is
a nice tip. And Lynn, you're saying this was also
accessible to everyone? Is that correct? Yep.
So the moving text, that's an
accessibility feature, I believe.
Yeah. Because sometimes for the effects, you will
have bouncy, wavy tax all over the screen. And if
you're not used to that kind of a graphics
display, you can turn it off. Amazing. Well,
I'm excited. I think everyone here just wants
to get to play the game. So let's get to it.
First off, I'm going to start by creating a new
game. Like I said, I've never played this before.
So I'm going on a journey with you. Okay, so here
we are on the screen, we are going to learn how to
code and this is essentially mimicking that right.
So here we are. I guess I'm being interviewed for
a job here where they've looked at my resume, and
they're going to give me an online assessment. So
let's do it. I guess I have no options. And we're
gonna look at the first question. So here we are
on the first question and what we how do you prove
that? Oh, okay. Ah, was that the question because
reading it Okay. Second question. Question. Yeah.
I didn't realize okay, well, obviously. Let's try
with the second question. Second question. In
Python. What is the generator so what banana
nuts I don't know. I'm guessing. Okay. Well,
that's that I've been interview. Time limit.
I am a bombing and these questions side question.
Okay. I'm gonna concentrate on the sun. How do you
why are they open? No knots and how do you explain
how it isn't? It was a five year old. Oh, my God.
I'm guessing this is on purpose. Right? I'm
not filming really? Haha. We're not taking you
straight to the bad ending. Not yet. Thanks for
taking the time to go to coding interview. Well,
that went bad. I really hoping that
somebody doesn't bog that coding journey.
Before you go, please take some time
to fill in your basic information.
Okay, cool. Wow, if that's what the game is gonna
be like, I'm just gonna give up now. Lynn? Good.
Dude, looks like I survived the technical
question. Barely. I would not say that was
the case. I'm just going to fill in my details.
I'm assuming. How did you hear about us? Okay,
I'm gonna go for fairoaks I'm going
to put you then. That's to that.
Oh, that's cool. I was referred by a VIP
member. That's pretty awesome. Then I guess your
VIP team member will make sure to that
VIP Team member didn't know. So I like
that feature. You're obviously Oh, that's an
achievement unlocked? Who got an Easter egg?
Amazing. So this 54 achievements to
be unlocked. I just got the first one.
I'm guessing I can tweet about it.
Right? Right. So if I just click on this,
I just got referred by a VIP member. That's pretty
cool. I'm not going to share it now because this
game is not live. So I don't want people or should
I tweet it? What do you think then? I keep it a
secret for now. Okay, I'm gonna keep this secret.
Okay, so obviously, you guys can tweet about
your achievements. So I'm just gonna continue
playing. What I did, okay. I'm gonna click Yes,
way to go. So now I'm notified about events
and opportunities. I like how realistic this
is in terms of you know, the process for when
you are applying for jobs and stuff. Okay, so
here we go. On your side. That was exhausting.
There's no doubt that I bombed those questions
I did. I did not do very well. Geez. Coding
interviews are hard. They are hard. They are hard.
I completely agree. What we what made me think
I could get a software job in the first place.
Okay, so now I think we're going back in
time. Well, it all started some time ago.
About three months ago to be exact. Let's learn
to code. Okay, so we've gone back in time.
August 1, I believe. And I'm in high school. Oh,
okay. That's what the module is all about. Yep.
The basis of Fernand. True. Okay, I need to reread
my notes. Make sure I have everything for the day.
So this is okay. All I see. I'm tutoring high
school kids at the moment. I've graduated from
college, but getting a full time job is very
difficult. I've heard back from none other jobs
that I have just applied for. And even though
I like tutoring kids, you need a full time. I
need a full time job that is more filling and
of course, pays more money pays the bills.
And the kid asked me hey, Anya. Oh, hey, sorry, I
just spaced out a bit. daydreaming about new jobs.
Do you have any more questions before we wrap
up? No, I think my project report is good to go.
Thanks. Okay. I'll see you next week. Sorry, can
we do the week often next? I just heard about a
new class that teaches you how to code and build
robots. And I need to check that. And I need to
check that out next week. Sure, no problem.
See you that your high school students are
beating you at learn to code already. Oh, no. I
was thinking like, am I gonna join this class?
But I'm at home now. My mom says Hey, sweetie,
welcome back. Welcome, pumpkin. How's your day?
My mom has a high school teacher, which is why
she could find him his tutoring gig and my dad
is a mechanical engineer. But I never got too
into engineering. Not to brag, but they are the
nicest parents. I know. I like that. That's really
soon. I had an okay day. I'm tutoring the Smart
kid wants to take up coding classes. I can't
believe that came from a high school student.
Yeah. So I'm obviously feeling like
I want to do some coding the moment.
And my mom is telling me that high school students
are enrolling into coding classes as it's trendy.
That's I don't know. I mean, I reckon that's
pretty true. I didn't do coding in high school,
but I guess maybe now's a different time. Yeah,
remember our neighbor, the guy who moved away last
month I had his kid in major in computer science
at college. The kid is only a Junior was already
interning for big companies during summer breaks.
Wow, that's pretty cool. That is pretty cool.
Dinner's ready. Thanks, Mom. You're the best.
That was cute. I like this Oh dumplings.
I'm enjoying the journey that I've been taking
on. So here's the best part about my day.
So we're having conversation and I'm
up for anything. And he has my room.
And notification from my phone must be
something on social media. What do we do?
I'm gonna obviously I'm gonna check my phone.
I'm not gonna ignore let's go for that one.
Looks like someone from my junior high
school. I don't even remember who they are.
What did they post to get this crazy
number of likes? Oh, fancy text?
Yes, that is cool. How did you make this go? So
bouncy? Is that a Python thing? Or is that a?
How did you how did you do that? It's a Python.
I run Python. There are those special tax tags
that you can use to make animated effects.
Oh, fun. Okay. I haven't checked out rampy
before But I love it. It's looking cool.
And I love swag. Who doesn't love swag?
Should I leave a like or comment on that post?
course we're gonna leave a like to leave a
like, who should we comment? What should we do?
I'm going to leave a like, like, wow, they've
got 1k likes already? Guess I'm one of them now.
Looks like you just made your first in game
choice. That's awesome. So how do you make the
choices limb is? Do you want to share some code as
in how you wrote that in Rambu? Because that's the
first sort of, I guess, choice that we have to do.
Or the second also? Yeah, sure. Let me just get my
script ready. Would you mind sharing so that I can
take over this year? Yeah. All right. Do you see
my screen? Yes. Alright, so we have over learn
to code RPG here. This is the run pi launcher.
And I'm just gonna open up the script and go back
to the place where we are asked to leave a like.
So here's how it looks in code, the player is
smiling, we changed the player sprite to the
smiley Sprite, should I leave a like a comment?
You leave a like, there's a different dialogue. If
you post a comment, there's a different dialogue.
If you do something, there's a different dialogue.
And you can see the choices are nested. Because
you chose to check the phone, you got taken to
this part of the conversation. If you did nothing.
Instead, you just have a relaxing evening.
Amazing. And this choice that we make it
doesn't have any consequence or anything
further at the moment, right? It just, it just
affects what texts will be returned back to you.
Yeah, you cut my developer comment there. There
there are more choices down the line, or actually
do something to the part of the story. Okay,
great. That's really exciting. Thanks for
sharing that we'll be cutting into code as
we continue playing the game as well. So
just be aware of that. I'm gonna go ahead and
share my screen. Okay, so back to the game.
Let's continue the game. I'm going to click to
continue. You will encounter many choices in
this game later on. There are no right or wrong
choices, only consequences. So maybe you gotta do
to save your progress. Okay, that's a good idea.
Let's go ahead and save our progress for added
thank you for the reminder. Okay, so
let's go in this empty slot. Wonderful.
I'm returned back. I like the save progress
function with the empty slot. That's really cool.
Yeah, that's actually built into our empire. So
I didn't have to do much heavy lifting. Amazing.
Would you like to get future reminders
on your set? Yes. Just keep reminders on
unclick. Yes. Oops. Cool. And Centennial friendly
reminder. Now let's go back to our story.
Oops, did I just doze off something about
coding interviews, not the Coding Interview.
It's crazy. I needed to learn code and
getting high paying jobs and software.
Six months of self placed learning and then a six
figure job. Talk about the end of craziness. Hmm,
I can see the appeal in that. Maybe I can learn to
code as well. Oh, that's cute. Hello, little mint.
The categories with me? So that's good. That's
a good side. Movement is definitely one of the
reasons I decided to move back home. Alright,
let's do this. A bit of research on heart. Where
should we start? Maybe I should find some free
online resources like everyone else is doing
well. We know great, free resource free cookout.
So let's here's a video about the top 10 tech
skills worth learning in 2021. Let's check that
out. I'll keep track of my progress on my phone.
Okay, so let's click on the phone to check
out our stats. So here we are. We are
Googling some stats. So Java and
JavaScript are different languages.
Wait, which one is for web dev? Again? I was
insanity, CS knowledge. So that is showing us
sanity decreases. Okay. So that's our sanity
as a person. And as our computer
science knowledge, that's pretty cool.
I remember one video saying that python two is
outdated. Does that mean I don't have to learn it.
Oh, maybe I shouldn't even
bother learn with python three
several majors decide that python three is too old
fashioned before I even get a chance to learn it.
Or what what am I doing? Java doesn't sound
like a good idea either. It's really old.
People nowadays are so hyped about Kotlin.
Why is my sanity decreasing?
If I click Show to do my
it's actually not decreasing. It's
just you're advancing the dialogues.
Oh, I see. Ok. JavaScript or TypeScript? Are they
like cousins or something? Maybe I could, oh,
maybe I can find a job posting I like
and start learning the required skills.
But why is front end back end or
full stack? What are the differences?
What are DevOps and Site Reliability
Engineering? And why is this compute?
Why is this company using that pep coding language
that nobody else uses? Ah, this is so frustrating.
I got the notification that your CS knowledge is
set to 00 I see. Okay, so at the moment, we've got
basis zero, and we're gonna increase this computer
science knowledge. I'm guessing along the way.
Yeah. And keeping your sanity at an acceptable
level of nice. Okay. Then Dakota, I guess it's not
that easy. There might be people who are called to
do this, but definitely not me. I guess I'd better
call it a day and go to bed. Oh, I definitely have
that. Have you ever not been able to sleep the two
years ago code on your mind because that happens
to me so much. I dream about code. And then when
I wake up, I can start writing code and debugging.
I've definitely like laid away because I'm just so
frustrated thinking about something or just even
like planning my next day and like, I'm just like,
okay, so tomorrow has to do this. Maybe I can
try this. But uh, yeah, like there's many nights
where I have not been able to sleep because as
soon as you pay the bills, even my parents are
nice enough not to ask for rent. Let's check out
the coffee shop next door tomorrow and CFF hiring
a learning buddies make it better I like it
how it's broken up into chapters as well.
Under a passive injection cool
from the neighborhood coffee.
Oh. Annika cheese. When was the last time
you called me when we moving out after
graduation? I know as friends. College best friend
right there. Oh, nice. Okay, well, yes. Annika, my
best friend from college is here to join the game.
Anyways, it's really nice to hear from you again.
Same Have you been? I've been okay. Just new
ground blues. You things are going pretty well.
For me. I just got a job offer. And like it's
not just any job. It's a web development job.
What has this guy got a web development job? And
we don't? Yeah. Can you believe it? I get paid
really well to build cool websites. It's almost
like getting paid for being creative and doing up.
Wow, congrats. Hey, Amica How hard was it for
you to learn to develop websites? I also tried
to learn to code for a while, but I got too
hot and I quit. I'm sorry to hear that. But
you should give coding another try. That's true.
That's true is quite hard. At the beginning, it's
definitely harder than people say sometimes. I
think it's easy, like easy peasy. It wasn't easy.
It wasn't like easy peasy for me either. Like
neither of us majored in computer science.
The computer science kids have a way easier
time getting a tech job. You did take some CSS
excellent score, didn't you? Yeah, but those
skills are pretty rusty and honestly what you
learn is that is true what your score just becomes
becomes outdated as well I feel right pretty quick
Yeah, and I feel at school you know,
you learn HTML and CSS and pretty much stops
that there are only so did for me anyway.
I've been self studying what isn't one season
also free resources. I even go to pet adoption
website as a side project. And that's my plan.
Okay, that's pretty cool. And there was this bug
that I had no idea how to fix until dot dot dot
suspense. Oh, I've been talking for a long time.
No worries. It doesn't you're
doing something you enjoy.
That must be really cool. I wish I could be
like you well, actually, you can use curly can
I get I did I give you the link to the awesome
resource that I've been using. It's called free
coke out when you hover over it. It's something
that you can actually check out. Amazing. Okay,
cool. So it takes you to To the I guess just to
the homepage of Freako camp with some alumni.
That's an in game title drop. Oh, yeah, I like
that. Well, they're officially called engaged
sim game title drop shipping. I just came up with
it right. Like a Tom that was widely adopted.
Thanks. So well, let's add it
to my to do list. Great. Okay,
we actually already did this. That's quite cool.
I like how it's incorporated into the gameplay
show to do is how do I want to
click it again for it to register?
No, this will be checked off sometime later
in the game. Oh, I see. What's your plan
for the day? I need to check out the neighboring
coffee shop. Oh, yeah, cuz we're getting a job.
Let's catch up some time we get coffee. Sure,
chat later. On that's clicks. So I'm gonna keep
saving anything do return and they will take
it will take you to the page. If I return.
Yeah, just click to continue and it
will take you to the page. Oh, I see.
Okay, cool. Yes. That's good to know as well.
You didn't click on that install to save so it's
probably not saved yet, but that shouldn't be
too much on performance. Okay, well, the next
time I guess we can do that properly. You can you
know, save it whenever you like just hit escape.
Yeah, this or escape and save it whenever. And
then, alright, because that's what we saved last
time. So if I click here, if you click on
the first one, it will overwrite the save.
You haven't even the number of saves available.
So no worries. That's good to note as well.
Okay, so at the moment we're at a coffee
shop. And he is a part time barista.
This reminds me so much of college I used
to work part time as a barista at the school
library Cafe as well. It was nice to see
my peers socializing and doing coffee work
at the cafe. I love to work at cafes. An
additional perk is that I get first hand
knowledge of interesting things that
happened on campus. Let's have a look.
I love that multimillion dollar startup,
not possible given not impossible, given that the
tech scene is booming in our quiet little town. Or
at least they might be talking about something
interesting happening in the tech industry.
Hey, did you hear that a school is getting a
computer lab. Wow, really? Okay. And the boys
asking her what happens at the computer lab. And
the girl is saying that we can build our own video
games. I love building games. And I heard that
we'll have a dedicated teacher to leave the club.
So even hers hackathons and stuff. That is
pretty cool. I I wish I did computer science
sometimes at university and got to take
part in hackathons, and stuff like that.
You know, like running a mile. I love this
description of a hackathon, like running a
marathon, but you can hack away at some project
instead of running around. It's actually needed.
You need the stamina and the snacks to survive
a hackathon. Just like a marathon. Have you done
any? Yeah. Water and sleep? I've done one or two
or have you? Well at university or a place you're
studying or just for fun? Yeah, the University
of Chicago does the college ones. Oh, cool.
Was it like a two day one or a one day one on the
two day war? Uh, wow. That was a stretch. Yeah.
Do you know about this thing called a visual
novel game? Tell me about it. Okay, here we go.
Hello, LA. I wasn't intentionally eavesdropping
on high school kids. But how can I say hackathon
idea they mentioned is new. I think I can use
this piece of information to my advantage.
Let's make it to that added. Let's make it a
to do list items. Ask Anika if she knows about
events like this, there's some good advice
actually, for people who are, you know,
sort of coding. I think being in the know about
events such as hackathons is definitely something
you should do, as Lynn mentioned, a while we just
secured another, we unlocked another achievement.
That's pretty awesome. We have we have a lot
more to go this is great. This is a fun game
and it's we're gonna have a lot of knowledge
by the end of the hour, I can already tell.
And the first thought is your undercover identity
for collecting passwords. Keep that in mind.
Okay, like the title Cool. baristas are going to
remember the word barista
as an undercover identity
you spent a long day at work. Let's check out the
awesome resource that Anika was talking about.
What was the cause? Again? I mean, I think I've
got an unfair advantage here. Because I definitely
never showed it is what happens if we show click
another one like freebie goodies? Go for it.
That doesn't sound the right name. I
never we must be playing tricks on me.
Okay, well, we know it's
free coke. But there's just
Wow, that's great. You'll have a super
comprehensive, they also offer certifications
that I can showcase on my resume beat. That
is pretty neat. What should I start with?
Okay, surely let's start at the beginning. Because
I think that's probably the best thing to do.
Yeah. Okay. Responsive Web Design. Why even
is web design? I'm not design person. Will
I be able to follow along? Maybe looks looks
okay. So we're not meant to choose that one.
I mean, she couldn't listen algorithms.
Oh, wait, maybe it's Java. Well, algorithm,
data structures. That sounds like
math, which is not my favorite subject.
What other curriculum options do I have? Hmm, I
feel like it's trying to make me pick something.
Shall we just wait, the honor, because advice
or should we pick or not? Let's just do that.
Let's ask Anika for advice tomorrow. Cool.
So that's added to my to do list? Nice.
The cat comes back and many things are some
great ideas that are Amaka. So that's what
we're going with. We're sticking with that
book. And let's save. Yes, we do want to say,
if you get annoyed by this a reminder, just turn
it off. Okay, I think for now it's fine. Maybe
we'll switch off the next one. Thanks for
entertaining, friendly reminder. Next day.
It's a new day already. What's
on our to do list today?
Right, let's give an go kart and ask
about the computer science curriculum.
What's up? So I've been checking out clicker
companies just said and I think it's crucial.
It's solid. The thing is, I have no idea what
to learn. Okay, so Annika is going to give us
all the advice, because we think it looks very
complicated. And you know, there's a lot of work
as she said with you certification.
So it's good to know where to start.
And Annika says that she did the web
design work. Okay, good. Okay, great. So
this is what we're gonna start Annika sending
us this one she did. And I think it will be a
good one first to start with as well. She
managed to pull through the curriculum,
because she had some experience from college.
Plus, she has a real different design.
I'm not like that. Apparently. There's no way
I can do this. I say, but I think I can. So
Anika agrees with me. She's gonna encourage me,
which is a good idea. I think already. It's a
big step forward now that you checked out their
curriculum. Trust me, I was just like you when I
first started, I was clueless. So reached out to
eco comms online community. That's also a great
idea. Anika is very clever. Yeah. Great advice.
Great. Yeah, the Forum is a great place to check
out bias and to know where to start. Yes. Thank
you, Lynn. So they also recommended that we start
with some general introduction to computer
science or quizzes. So let's check it out.
Oh, yes. Okay, so these are the certifications
that we got sent to before. And all you have to
do is really sign up to see the web development,
responsive design questions that are on here.
Okay, so if you haven't already, please sign
up, it is free. And then you'll get taken to
some responsive questions. I mean, I
should already be able to into this. So
there we go. So here's the
responsive web design certification,
and you just go through each of these
questions and try complete them. Okay,
so that's all you have to do just go through
each one of them. There's 28. Little, I guess,
collapsible courses that you can get through and
then you go into CSS and so on and so on. So just
make sure to do this in order and then you will
finish the responsive web design course. Great.
Yes, so they are really bite sized.
They are quite fun. And essentially,
you just go through them
and try pass each question
and you're saying that she's not
sure if she can complete them.
And what happens if we run into somebody we can't
understand? Well, again, we have the community
right loan. So the community is also on hand to
help you. There's a channel especially for this.
So if you ever get stuck, just go on someone
from Freako camp or the free poker community
will be able to help you with your questions. And
Annika is also saying that she's going to be our
accountability, buddy. Great. That's good.
Thanks out and she really is a best friend
Anya and Annika forever by okay,
because heading up work. Best of luck.
Okay, so that's one more item that we
can check off our to do list. Great.
Time to go to my barista shift.
Okay, I'm going to turn them off now. I'm going to
say my progress again. So now I've just turned off
the Save reminders just for everyone following
along. You can go to settings and turn it on or
off at any time. Okay, so that's also something
you can do. Yeah, the others, there's a saving,
save reminder. Tax right there. Okay, so I'll
turn it off by making sure that it is disabled.
And let's carry on. Okay, so we're back at the
cafe back are workship. But today, there's not
many people. Okay. So I guess we'll make ourselves
a coffee. I mean, what developer doesn't like
coffee? I personally love decaf coffee. And while
that was, that's great, because our shift is over.
We're gonna do some studying, we finished those
shifts. And now let's go to studying some zones.
So let's head over to develop a
quiz and try out some questions.
Actually, you might want to just go back to
the game. And there will be in game quizzes.
Okay, looks like they even divided the
questions. The sub Patrick is like HTML, CSS,
and JavaScript. And wonderful. I like how
there's a tracker that's really helpful,
and I think will really help us sort of
understand how far along we are with our learning.
So I think that's a really good feature. How did
you make that feature? By the way? Should we go
into code for that? I think that might be a good
idea. Yeah, sounds great. Let's go to the file
where I should be Claire, stop star RP. So
the dot RPI file tells RAM pi dot run pi file.
Run pi is based on Python. So all the code we're
seeing here are like Python code. So we have a
stats map where you see the 70, and Cs knowledge.
There's also something called all skills that I
defined somewhere else in verbose to Rp,
RP. Why? Before I show you the skills,
I'm just gonna quickly show the layout. So we have
sanity here, I'm using the grid to display the
thing, if you remember, there's a sanity, there's
a CS knowledge. And for each subcategory of
knowledge, we also make that part of the screen.
So you can see a will always have stats name
and a bar value. And yeah, that's pretty much
it. variables. Variables is where we keep our
end game secrets. Great. So whenever we complete
a section you read, we're just adding a value
to one of the variables, right. One of the skills,
right, amazing. I mean, that's really good to see
and code, I really appreciate you showing us that.
Alright, cool. So let's carry on and let's give
it a go. Should I study for a specific category
or mix and match categories? I think specific.
Let's just go specific for now and start with
the very first one, I think, or should we do
HTML language one don't do up to you. Let's do it.
HTML. Okay, HTML it is. So first off, of course,
it's nice to know HTML actually stands for as
well. Let's go for it. Yeah, we're sorry. We
have a total of over 600 questions. You know,
a question back. Wow. Okay. That is, I mean,
I'm so impressed with how much And bear in mind
everyone, we're just on achievement number two.
So that is a lot to this game by the end, like
all our knowledge of computer science and web
development is going to be crazy high, especially
if you've never done development before.
So what is the title tag in haitch tml, the
title tag and subtitle position, heading to the
paragraph defines the title for HTML document. So
you're just going to be asked lots of questions.
And of course, if you get it right, you get a
correct. You got a Oh, I got 10 points. Cool.
Nice. And I guess if you don't get it right, then
it might show you my you know, shoot, let's try
and get what I'm incorrect answer. So what's
cool spawn, I'm just gonna go with something.
Okay, so wrong, it just sort of vibrates.
And then it gives you the correct answer.
So that's quite useful as well. Because,
sorry, carry on, we're gonna say something.
There's a Learn More button if you hover over it.
Yeah, nice. Doesn't go more in depth
into the subject into the question,
you can always check out it in the article. So
this is incredible. I can't even imagine how much
work this had to be not only to create the
questions, but then to you know, find an
article or a piece of information on free COCOM
to essentially link to to allow someone to read
more and more about the topic. That's amazing.
Really, yeah, I had a lot. I had a few people on
the team to help me out to come up with questions
and organize them. Do you want to see a quick?
Yeah, I want to quickly see it in code. And
you will be amazed by the number of questions.
Wow, this Yes. As questions. It's a long scroll.
So for each string, we've got the true the false,
the explanation, the Learn More URL, and
everything. It's a long scroll. I like how
it's a difficulty one as well. And bear in mind
these quiz questions for everything for all the
for all the quiz, okay. Wow, that's
incredible. I can see how this would have taken
a crazy amount of time. I'm so so impressed.
Carry about JavaScript was it's a it's a long
scroll to the bottom. Yeah, we're already on 3800.
So I mean, if you could only imagine how many
questions that will take up. That is crazy.
I love it. Alright, awesome.
Thanks. Okay. Let's move on.
Correct code for linking CSS stylesheet to an
HTML file. So these are essentially all the
swans That's right. Doesn't need an end tag.
Okay, good. So there we go. So we've just
increased our spawn HTML that would have been
30 is the second one we've been get incorrect
on purpose to see the incorrect I guess, gameplay
and plans. Let's carry on. Last question, actually
what attributes choose you? What attributes should
you add input to create a checkbox checkbox that
was an easy one to address okay. That also it's
good to see sort of I really liked the learn
more functionality I thought that was really
good. And it was great to see that in my Whoa,
well done. Another achievement I love So HTML
achievement is now a lot that is pretty cool. It's
saved to the bonus menu so we can also tweet about
it of course I'm not going to do it now because
this is not yet released at the moment of
recording it will be released by the time
that you watch this so yeah, I will be
obviously that makes sense because yes,
that will be officially launched what I'm saying
the game will be officially launch by the time
we would like to go to the bonus screen. Yes,
let's do it. Let's go to the bonus screen.
How do I get there settings and then
that fun site? Achievements achievement.
Oh, nice. So that's the easter egg that
we found. I love that there's so many does
this mean that It was true that we've missed
two easter eggs that we've missed. Mm hmm.
So if you really want and you complete the
game, you can go through the game again
to try and find all the easter eggs. That could
be a fun side, like a side mission in itself.
Great. So there is a lot to unlock. I mean,
I think once we've got to the coding part,
it's, it's rare, it's really gonna take a lot
of brainpower. So don't feel you have to do
everything in one go. If you're just learning
to code, it could be worth, you know, taking
a break to do some additional learning why
you're doing this game, there's nothing that
you know is forcing you to do this. You
know, just directly step by step by step.
Cool. So we are now tired after a
long day of work, we have achieved
and unlocked the HMO achievement. So now the
say goodnight to meant and go to the next day.
I also like how the day is in the corner as a
sort of other way to track your progress, I guess.
So how do you calculate the date from the back?
Is this calculated based on today's date? Does
it go back in time three months? Or is it just an
arbitrary date that you have? It's a hard coded
one. Oh, nice. Okay, cool. Because the recruiting
process for tech companies usually start around
October and November. And that's where you
will learn something about coding and are
ready to tackle those coding interviews.
Okay, I get it. That makes sense. I like
let's go to the kitchen. And do all these
animations. Did you say you worked with an
artist to create them? Those transitions
are actually built into red pipe. But
this character sprites you see on the side, and
Omnicom sprites, these are created by the artist
and the background images are just stock images.
And I applied some water color filter to them.
So they look like no game backgrounds. I can't
believe that that's such a good idea. I mean,
I can't believe that's an image that used for
a stock photo. Yes. But the drawings of the
characters are amazing. So whoever the artist is
shout out. Shout out to them for sure. And the
toes is drawn by me because my artist wanted to
focus on creating characters. Oh, cute. I love it.
How did you make the drawing?
Like what did you use?
Oh, I I do digital art on the side.
So I have like drawing apps on my
iPad and my Apple Pencil. Amazing. And I drew
meat. That's like the one thing I'm proud of.
I love men. What a great side Terisa. Oh, do
you want to mix and match this mix and match?
Mixing and matching all categories? Sounds
like fun. Let's bring in the popery?
Great first question, what is the name of
the rule that will override CSS style for an
element? I actually don't know this. Let's go with
override. I want to say important. But this is a
question. I don't know. So we grew grew Blue Blue
Origin notice override it was important. I knew
that was intentional. Always go with your gut,
apparently. But also the person who came up
with a quiz question did a really good job of
creating all those distractors? Yeah. I mean,
yeah, that was a that was a great question.
If you watch my YouTube videos, you'll know
my CSS knowledge isn't super great. I'm mainly
focused on JavaScript and React and stuff.
So let's see how I do this. RGB stands for
red, green and blue. So I know that one.
He was an external JavaScript
file without a script. Correct.
Form. Cool. So as you can see, again, we have now
completed more questions on HTML. That was HTML,
right? Wasn't it any more section? Oh, it didn't
mix and match. But because we have the most number
of HTML questions. If we're drawing randomly
from the sample, it will just show up more often.
Great. Okay. So yes, we did a mix and match
one. So that is quite good as obviously then
you don't really know what to expect. And Annika
sparks Okay, so Annika Hey Ania now's perfect,
just got back from work. Anika is going to
tell us that we're great. And we're awesome.
Oh, she's loves us the custom web framework that
her company uses is pretty different. Okay, that's
interesting, and exciting. So I like how we get to
sort of Anika, because she gives us some insight
into what it's like to work at an actual software
development company, which I think is always
interesting to hear, especially when
you're, you know, just starting out.
She's had a lot of good things about this
framework that she's using, mostly from people
that she ran into at the local Hackerspace. That
is cool hackathons. Okay, great. This is a great
reminder, because we're going to ask Annika about
hackathons. And she's also mentioned hacker space.
Hello, Anya, we're obviously daydreaming
about hacker space. What topic we're
gonna ask her about? Well, let's ask. Let's
start off with asking her about hackathons.
And, as Lynn mentioned, it is an
event that people come together
and essentially, design and implement cool tech
projects, then was two days where you can get
24 hour hackathons, you can get all remote
hackathons. There's, there's really like,
they've taken the idea of a hackathon. And it's
sort of evolved into anything that anyone wants,
which I think is quite cool. And
yes, it's also a great way to,
to mingle with people who perhaps, are at a
different level to you, which is always quite
useful, or a great way to network with people
who work at specific companies. So for example,
say you want to work at a specific company, and
that during a hackathon, and you would potentially
like to work there, or just learn what it's
like to work about what it's like to work there,
I would definitely suggest going. And yes, as
Anika says, Great, they look great on your resume.
And searching online is definitely a great way to
find them. There's plenty of resources out there.
Twitter's or is a good one, I think to stay on
top of news about hackathons or just events in the
computer science space. So great. Thanks,
Annika for that knowledge, and we can also
not check it off our list. And we can also learn
about hacker space. So that wasn't obviously
just a question. We can select all the answers
if we want and go through them. hacker space
is something that I haven't had. I haven't
heard of it. Perhaps it's a geographical thing.
As hackerspace isn't the cyber criminal criminal
types of hackers it's a chill space with people
to gather work and build cool projects. It's
almost like a shared co working environment.
Where do you just come together and build stuff?
That's where to cool. might check it out as well.
So is it a an in person thing or an online thing?
Mostly in person? Like when I first moved here
to San Francisco Quincy was highly suggesting
something called Noisebridge I think but I haven't
had a chance to go there because of COVID Yeah,
of course. Yeah. I don't know if we have any of
those in London. There's definitely hackathons
but not hacker spaces. So if there is one in
London that I should hear about and every anyone
out there knows have one please let me know.
Great, that's everything I need to know. Thanks,
Annika. Annika is like great. I love her.
Everyone needs an Annika in their
lives. Especially if you're starting
to learn into code you need a
body like this. Yeah for sure.
Thanks, and well done
I love the little insights into my
life at home with my mom and dad as
well. And some chicken today I learned you
animated the chicken as well you do that?
Yeah. Great all such supportive
parents as well. So that's really nice
great, so another another day of learning is now
done. And we're going to bed. I wonder if it's
worth you know, if you are playing this game
and you are learning to code through the game.
I wonder if it's worth, you know, calling it
a day at the same time as your character calls
it a day. What do you think, Lynne? Is that the
way the game is intended? Oh, whatever whenever
you need to reach Hard tickets take some time off
but they're also in game way to recharge. As you
will see soon. Nice. Okay, well hopefully we'll
get to one of those soon. Remember you need to
keep your sanity up and oh yeah both of your in
game sanity and in life sanity up. Okay, cool
if we check how do we check
our current sanity stat
stats? So our salaries in 75 I
think that's quite high for sanity
I think today What shall we do? Okay, well, if
we work that will bring down our sovereignty
if we study again, they'll take let's let's
just relax let's get our sovereignty way up.
Yeah, let's hang out a minute for a day.
Let's listen to some music. As
we said, Quincy made the music
so let's maybe pick a track that we want to listen
to. Let's go with crystallize that inner child.
Yeah, so if you are interested in seeing the music
that Quincy made, you can see all the tracks here
and have a listen. So take a chill, relax, get
up that sanity before continuing to play order
where we got an achievement. Is that because
we listened to the game? Yes, Toby sucker.
Nice. So that is achievement that you can unlock
as well just like listening to some of the amazing
music that is on the game. And we've increased
our sanity by 17. So that is what happens if
our sanity gets to Nolan. We're not able to
continue playing. Yeah, you might be alright,
I'm gonna keep this a secret you might be forced
into doing some activities that will eventually
raise your sanity. Or you might encounter some
special Easter eggs. Oh, nothing. Ah, okay.
So maybe maybe you want to exhaust yourself
just for fun? Just to see what happened
Okay, great.
Remember, during your virus that shift you
can always catch some cool tech buzzwords to
ask Annika or your friends about Okay, great.
So that's something we should remember as well
okay
so now we just woken up and
let's get on with the day.
So today let's go maybe work at the bar. Let's
try let's try pick up some cool buzzwords.
And let's have some coffee and see who else we can
meet at the coffee shop. We chosen the coffee shop
on purpose to essentially try build up our network
Okay, so it was it was quite a four hour hire or
thought out job decision for me so here
we're over here in compensation via API's.
And if you don't know what API's you can
actually learn quite a lot about them just
by listening conversation, knowing that you can
build your own or knowing that you can, you know,
use ones that are already out there and
exist. So here we go. What is an API?
And we better take some notes on this subject
and some study actually increased.
That's interesting. Because it Yeah,
is it a coffee from the coffee and
like the only thing exhausting you're doing the
game is probably just pick your mining to study
sounds like we enjoyed our day
okay, do we have any cool times? Well,
we know we do. Let's push we say oh,
we can save the buzzer for later. That's cool. I
want to see what happens if we save the buzzword.
Is there a list of buzzwords? Okay, so let's
check out the list. buzzwords. Always remember,
you can check out the list of buzzwords
in your stats to do. So here are my stats
learn about API. So that is saved as a buzzword.
We didn't ask Arthur about it. We saved it for
another time. But I'm sure we can ask Annika. Now.
Oh, cool. We're going to hackerspace this dread.
That's why local hackers love to hang out
here. Why don't we go around and check out
what people are working on? Sounds good. Okay, I'm
loving this. See, as a developer or someone new
to developing, you're going to pick up a
lot of words here. Like even like prototype.
Obviously, Hackathon is one that we
already covered. We can eavesdrop on
interviews. I'm not saying we use your phone,
everything. That'd be creepy, of course,
but just being surrounded by words, sometimes
whiteboarding, you know, all these words that
you know, you could be like, Oh, we can ask Amica
later about are really, really kind of important.
And, of course, interview secrets, we
need to talk to young female over here.
What do you think about this place? It's amazing.
That is true. It is, it does seem pretty
cool. And again, if you do have a hackerspace
near you, it is kind of like this, like you
do hear lots of interesting conversations,
and you meet a lot of interesting people.
So there's our achievement unlocked. And as
newbies we have learned about hackerspaces,
and what is like to hang out at them.
Great. So we are literally increasing our
knowledge so much at the moment, not just by
answering questions is, which is what I like,
we're not just going through the curriculum,
were actually gaining a lot of, you know, other
knowledge when it comes to getting a job in tech.
So which one should we do today? Learn? Whichever
you feel like doing? Okay, so today, let's
study some see, I want to ask about API's.
So maybe let's try get Annika back in some
form of way. Or let's, let's just do some CS,
choosing a specific category. So now I'm going
to Whoo, she's a specific category. Let's do
general computer science concepts this time.
Okay. So this could be an interesting one.
The process of finding and fixing bugs in
a computer program is known as debugging.
Great. So we've just increased. So again, I think
I mean, for me, this is like super fun as well.
And seeing the overall progress we have a fantasy
is 97. And that is so good. So essentially, now
you could just literally like go through all of
these without really worrying about your science
Santa zoo too much. You're taking such good care
of yourself, if you're a mental well being. Yeah.
The the first way which a function calls itself
directly, indirectly is known as with caution. On
third question, values that an operator
operates on are known as operands.
Cool. So there's, I think there's four questions
each time is that correct? Correct. Great. All
right, your car, your total CS knowledge is
now at 11. Because it's a average over all
the other stats. Oh, nice. Oh, that is pretty
cool. So great. We've answered some questions.
And it's time for dinner again, and dumplings.
So this is good. Again, I feel like we are
progressing very nicely in the game. But there
is still a lot to learn. Like already in my mind.
I'm like, What are API's? If I was a beginner,
that would be I'd be like, Oh, what are they?
And rather than learning more questions we can
give anigre course so we did it. So this is what
I mean about like, it's quite exciting in terms
of, you know, your learner journey. You can't
just go directly to the answer you need to figure
out a way to get the answer to so let's go on and
I think Annika started becoming my
favorite thing. Other characters
are more characters and you have meat. Oh,
amazing. So API, let's learn about the OBO.
And why is everyone going around using acronyms?
That is so true. There's so many acronyms in
computer science and programming. So here Annika
tells us wasn't API is the weather app. I mean,
everyone on their journey as a software
developer has probably made a weather app
at some point. So I hope we get to build
one too, or if not just learn about what a
weather app does and how it works. And Annika
here will tell us how to do that. And we can
take it off. Anything else? That sort of, so
I guess every time we get a buzzword saved,
it comes becomes an option for us to ask
Anika is that right? All right. Whoo.
Great. So there we go. Um, thanks, man. Okay, so
now let's go back to hang out at the hackerspace
because it does more to do in this area.
So let's go around and I work tech trivia
that is pretty fun. Sure. Let's do a
trivia guy. So I'm guessing this is one of the
games that we come across. Let's see how we do.
Let's do this. Here's the first question. What was
the original name for Java? I actually don't know
this. Let's go with homebrew. I know that's wrong.
What was it was that Oh, I thought maybe it was
homebrew exists. It's just sort of moved over.
But that was wrong isn't it Monty Python?
Correct. You don't know how I even knew that.
Oh my god, C++, but I think it's this one. No,
I don't know. Oh, I don't I don't
even remember. stay alone while Oh,
I have no clue. This trivia is really hard.
Do you know? Yeah, the one that's related to
then stone maybe stone next question, which has
more precision double float the double double
next, trivia questions are hard but if you get all
correct there might be some good things happening
to say oh my god these are really hard I
didn't know that either. Lovelace was a poet
if you get them all correct
something fun happens as
a legal identify an assembly
language Jesus I don't know.
Better luck next time Okay, so I mean I'm
guessing there's a lot of these I'm guessing
the questions won't be the same or they might
be I don't know. But try again try get them all
correct because there is a special thing
that shows up if you do get them right
also, that was a long day
I like to load recaps the conclusions of the
day that I share with my mom was quite fun
Do I have any cool tech times no nothing on
my list today. But I enjoy it I enjoy finding
the tool tax harm so that is definitely one of my
favorite activities. I think you know, because it
looks like you have read this part of the text
before you can use this skip function. Okay.
Cool. What should we do now? Relax for today.
Maybe? There might be something else you can
do. Let's play some video games. Check it out.
Nothing beats video games. a rhythm game. Okay,
let's go ahead and choose scratching the surface.
Use the arrow keys on the keyboard. Oh geez. Okay.
I mean, lucky. I think I know how to play this.
Ah, it's like that stepping game, isn't it?
And that's quite a song. Oh,
perfect. You're getting perfect
it's actually a lot harder than I thought.
It's designed to be hard, though. It's
getting faster as well oh my god. Ah
I don't think I get penalized for getting
it wrong though, which is quite good
is it done to the music? Or is it random? It's
actually down to the music. Yeah, I use song a
Python music onset detection feature. Okay, it's a
special like, yes, sound audio processing library
for that. And I was able to time the beats
to the music. Amazing. I was thinking like,
is this to the music? Can I somehow get more in
time? High School because that wasn't one before.
Is this the high school for me would
just in general with for every player
for you only for me only? Okay. Well, I'll
try beat myself next time. That is so far. And
I love that I love the little games. And if I
choose another one, it will be the game again.
That music Right? Right. Yeah. But you can see
how much you are missing from the perfect score.
I think we're discovered I'm not good at tech
trivia. And I'm not good at playing this game.
This is so cool, though. Can you share us how you
made this ENCODE? Perhaps? Oh, yeah. Let's do it.
So this is actually a lot of code to have this
screen where you select the song. And I have
the screen for the actual rhythm game. And
here's that entire displayable the host the
rhythm game, the notes you're seeing and basically
everything. Yeah, this is actually a side project
of mine that I will be I have been working
on for a long time, not just for this game.
I have the code on GitHub as
an open source. Free pool.
Amazing. Yeah, I made those into the engine
that anyone can plug into their RAM pie game.
And basically, that's it there. There's just so
much the code that I wouldn't be able to dive in
right now. But feel free to check this out. Yeah,
definitely. I think if we can, we should put this
in the description of the videos. If people can
check out your repo. Maybe have a go, you know,
just putting it down and playing around for
themselves. But yeah, I love it. That's that's
really impressive. Great. Now, I think maybe
let's, instead of going back to the game now
because I don't want to go through before game
for everyone. I want everyone to have a go at you
know, playing themselves. Let's maybe highlight
some of the favorite bits of the game that you
really enjoyed coding. So which parts of the game
were the most enjoyable for coding for you? And
I'd really like to see. Yeah. Okay, I'm going to
talk about two parts. So the first is how I come
I composited the character sprites. And then the
other part will be how, just when you see the like
de activity layout, how does it actually show up
in code? Just these two parts. Alright. Alright,
oh, I think a major highlight of this game is the
graphics and how it actually works in code. So you
might recall seeing all those NPC characters,
the non player characters that have different
colors. Actually, we only have one single image
for now. So images character, by the way, the
entire game is archived meaning that
you will actually be able to just
download the game and check out its
content and everything is open source.
Amazing So I can see this already milk houses
Lola Marco. Yeah. Alright. Yeah. So if you look,
we only have these four NPC sprites. But
if you remember correctly in the game,
they're actually tinted different
colors. That's a my definitions.
So we have those matrix matrix multiplication,
that you can use to create a red, orange,
blue and purple tint to the NPC characters.
Amazing. And, yeah, let's also demonstrate how
we it you might have noticed that the layer and
on the cot, they are blinking. And to do that,
there is something to do that we did some image
composition. So here's the base component will
Annika she's actually missing the eyebrows and
eyes and ml. But that's just me, that's just for
coding in her expressions. So this is a
neutral eyebrow. And this is like slightly
elevated. This is the coast i This is the laughing
Nai. This is a heart Octo eyes, mouth, smiling,
and different angles. And if you go here I'm
creating a dynamic blink component to omnicast
eyes. So we're alternating between the open eye
image and a closed eye image. So this and this.
That's cool. And then on the
call, we're always using her base
like this. If she has multiple sets of outfits,
we can use different bases as well. So maybe
maybe in the future, she will wear
a company branded t shirt. Yeah.
And then the group. We have the eyes, the eyebrows
and the mouth. And we have the expressions.
I love it. And how do you what is the time a
timing event to make her smile and close your
eyes and stuff? Like how does that work? Right?
Yeah, you can see here be there too. There are
three different expressions for Annika, she has a
serious face, a neutral face and a laughing face.
And the player has a lot more expressions. That's
just because she's a player. If we're remembering
these keywords mutual smile, happy surprise
laugh worry, we're going back into our script.
So we're showing Annika neutral and when the guy
says I'm sorry to hear that something something
and we show Annika serious. She's talking about
something else and we go back to the neutral
and for the player, we are doing it in
line. So it cost us nothing and a player
changes for expression to the laughing
expression. And so on and so forth.
Amazing. Right, and this is about this is about
that four character sprites. And I guess another
part of the game I really want to highlight is
your daily activities, which should be daily
activity choices. And you're always greeted
with this line, what should we do for the day,
your choices are to study CS fundamentals.
And we're gonna skip over this block because
it's just what happens when you study and what as
a barista. Here we're calling a different label
that will extend into the whole barista story
and handing out as to Hackerspace. under the
condition that you have already visited the
hackerspace with Annika This is a Boolean.
And then taking the day off, relax,
and we see those different labels.
For we go to the activity relax, we can
see we can take a walk in a park, which
in turn cause a different label that has something
to do with the park, play some video games.
Called the video game label and then listening
to music. We call it the music room screen.
And then for the hackerspace there's the
trivia guy, and a lot of other events like
random events. Now I'm not gonna spoil it for you.
And then barista, there's an entire barista story.
Park media game and ooh, job search that will
eventually happen But and yeah there's just so
much to the game Oh yeah, I can see how much there
is so a lot to look forward to. Now if we run the
run pilots later it was a it has so those many
dialog box these many words and then these many
menus, images and different screens so the GUI
components you see on the screen like the calendar
and the stops these are all screens we have these
many of them still do occur to you something else
happening the game down the road. Amazing.
Well, I love it. I think this is so exciting.
I can't wait to carry on playing on my own again.
I don't want to go through the whole game because
I don't want to ruin it for people who want to
give this a go themselves and hopefully complete
the game and definitely please do share your
progress with us by tweeting we'd love to see
you know how far you've gotten. Maybe who's you
know, finished the game fast? And so on. So yes,
if you finished the game, get that tweet out
so we can know and we can celebrate that.
Always remember to check out a bonus screen.
There's the rhythm games and music room.
The other links and awesome Freako camp resources.
Wonderful. Okay, well I think that's it for now.
Thank you so much Lynn up for taking me on
the trip for being on the journey with me
as I explore this game. And of
course, thank you so much for
building the game in the first place. This is
incredible. I'm so so incredibly impressed. I mean
like words can't even describe or thank you so
much for play through and I hope you enjoyed
it. I enjoyed it as much as I enjoyed building it.
Yeah, no, definitely it was it was really awesome.